[Music]
hi everyone my name is NIC de
Christopher oh I'm a customer engineer
and network specialist with Google cloud
and I'll be your presenter today in this
video if you started your journey
towards Google cloud from a hybrid
on-premises model it's likely that
you're already using some hybrid
connectivity features one of them being
cloud VPN historically cloud VPN offered
you an SLA of 99.9 percent and with the
introduction of our H a VPN solution we
now offer an SLA of 99.99% you're able
to benefit from higher availability as
well as ease of migration between
classic VPN and havvn in this video I
will show you how easy it is to migrate
an existing classic VPN tunnel to an H a
solution first let's look at two
migrations path we will look at today
the first one is migrate an existing
classic VPN solution to hav p.m. using
BGP as the routing protocol to
on-premises network or any non-google
networks and the second is migrate an
existing classic VPN utilizing policy
based VPN to hav p.m. utilizing bgp
between two projects or v pcs within
Google cloud platform now let's begin by
looking at the first example migration
path as you can see here I'm in the
hybrid connectivity section of the
Google cloud console here's a tab for
VPN and this is where I would like to
have a look at the VPN tunnels and the
cloud VPN gateways that are available
here you can see that I have two classic
VPN tunnels that are already established
if I scroll to the right you can see
that I have dynamic bgp VPN tunnel and I
have a policy based VPN tunnel for the
first section of this video we will
focus on the demo VPN tunnel that's
already established over BGP the first
thing you want to do is to create a new
cloud VPN gateway if I click the cloud
VPN tab gateway here you can see that I
have a classic VPN gateway with
associated IP address and I have an H a
VPN gateway already created if I click
create new VPN gateway this is where you
would create
your new VPN gateway for hav PN you
would give it a name under the VPN
gateway name and select an appropriate
VP C Network for the VPN gateway and
these would be the same VP C Network in
region that match your current classic
VPN my current classic VPN gateway is
configured in USD store so I would
select US East for I will not click
create because I've already created one
but in your case you would click create
so next if I go back to the cloud VPN
tunnels tab I'm asked to select a VPN
gateway and I will select the H a VPN
high availability gateway I just created
and click continue
I'm presented next with two options in
the first example we will look at an
on-premises or non Google cloud peer
gateway I've already created a new demo
non VPN gateway however in your case you
would need to click create pure VPN
gateway and then provide a name in this
case it would be the on-prem VPN gateway
and then specify the IP address of the
interfaces of your on-premise VPN
gateway now you may have 1 2 or 4
interfaces and this depends on your
vendors configuration and my test
environment I'm going to use two
interfaces with the same IP address
I'm not going to enter these right now
and click create because I've already
done so I will click cancel instead
instead I will click peer VPN gateway
name and shoot the VPN gateway I've
already created the next step is to ask
me what I would like to do with high
availability component now high
availability or hav pn provides a 99.99%
SLA and therefore it's required to
create a pair of VPN tunnels to achieve
that SLA next the only routing option we
have for hav pn is dynamic via bgp next
we want to select a cloud router you can
reuse the same cloud router that you
were using previously for the classic
VPN bgp tunnels if you'd like to create
a new cloud route or however it's not
necessary here I will select the
existing cloud router and next I will
create the tunnels as I select
added on the VPN tunnels you can see
that it automatically populates the
Associated interfaces from my H a VPN
gateway that was created earlier and an
associates appear gateway interfaces for
me if you remember I mentioned that I
have two interfaces for my peer gateway
and these interfaces have the same IP
address for the purposes of this demo
for the first tunnel I will associate
interface 0 of the HIV pn gateway with
interface 0 of the peer gateway I'll
give it a name let's call it h a VPN
tunnel - 0 next you can select the ike
foreign most modern VPN gateway support
ike v2 so i'll leave it at that
next enter a pre-shared key now for my
example the pre shared key is going to
be demo VPN h a VPN however please note
the best practice is to create a strong
like pre shared key see links to our
documentation below for more information
the generate and copy button here can
create one for you now click done next
I'll configure the second tunnel as you
can see this is associated with
interface one on both the hav P and
Gateway and peer gateway following the
same naming convention we will call this
H a VPN tunnel - one I'll enter the same
pre shared key
and clicked up now once you've
configured everything you can click
create and continue hey the next screen
we have to configure the bgp sessions
let's configure the bgp session for the
first cloud VPN tunnel
click configure here I will give it a
name let's call it h a VPN - BGP - zero
now fill in your pure autonomous system
number that's what's actually configured
on your on-premises environment in my
environment it's sixty five five zero
six next let's look at the multi exit
discriminator value or advertiser route
priority because we would like to
minimize a downtime and the recommended
configuration as an active active tunnel
I know that I've configured my default
route priority for my classic VPN tunnel
to 100 so I will configure the route
priority here to 1000 for the hav pn
tunnel what this means is that when
these tunnels come up traffic will not
automatically switch over to these
interfaces because the other tunnel has
better priority this effectively means
that we do not need to move traffic to
the new tunnels until we're ready to do
so now for all configuration changes
that you would do in the cloud we would
recommend them to be done during
maintenance windows next configure the
cloud router bgp IP and pure bgp IP the
IPS depend on what is configured in your
own premises environment in my case the
local cloud router bgp IP is 169.254 dot
4.1 and the BGP pure IP is 169 250 4.4.2
next you can configure the advertised
routes so you may decide to advertise
only certain routes across this tunnel
for the purpose of this demonstration
we're not going to change the defaults
and then we'll click Save and continue
next configure the second BGP session
with the desired parameters here I'll
configure with a similar naming
convention so here I will name it H a
VPN - BGP one the peer ASN is going to
be the same 6 5 5 0 6 next under the
route priority we'll be putting the same
med value so that the tunnels are in an
active active state so they're
essentially able to load balanced
traffic I will enter value 1000 the same
I enter in the other tunnel and
again for cloud router vgp IP and bgp
pure IP this depends on your
configuration for me it's 169 to 50 for
5.1 and the pure IP is 169 254 5.2 now
again let's click Save and continue
finally let's click the button to save
the BGP configuration
now here on step three we're actually
given a summary page with a current
status of our VPN tunnels you can see
that right now they're establishing so
it may take roughly 20 to 30 seconds to
bring up the tunnels so we'll click OK
and return to the previous page now
again on this page you can see a summary
of my cloud VPN tunnels as you can see
my right two tunnels are waiting for the
BGP peer to be established you may click
refresh here at the top of the page and
I'll actually refresh the screen so
we'll know whether the BGP have been
established so let's click refresh and
now you can see that the BGP are
established so next if we select the
hamburger menu at the top left hand side
and we scroll down to VPC network and on
under the networking section we will
select routes now in the routes tab I'm
interested in the dynamic tab to look at
the new routes that were learned across
havvn
if I click dynamic tab here I can see
that I'm learning a new IP prefix from
both tunnels with priority 1000 based on
the other VDP routing priority which is
set to 100 this means that the existing
classic VPN tunnel that I had previously
created would still take precedence
recall that a lower value is better here
meaning that 100 wins over 1,000 traffic
is still going to flow across the
existing VPN tunnel and not across the
new H a VPN tunnel so next as you can
see here I have a demo virtual machine
that I'm going to establish a ping
between it and my on-premises
environment across that VPN tunnel so
here I'm going to initiate a pain to
192.168.1 25.1 and as you can see I'm
receiving packets from that on-premises
machine which is located across the VPN
tunnel on my own premises network so
next to have seamless traffic failover
let's change around in priorities so
that the classic VPN tunnel has lower
priority or a higher med value than the
HIV 10 tunnels so if you click on the
hamburger menu at the top left hand side
go back to networking click hybrid
connectivity and then VPN
select the existing classic VPN tunnel
scroll down to the routing & Security
section and the line item BGP session
click modify BGP session when the new
window opens up
change the advertised route priority to
a value larger than what was configured
for hav PN tunnels for example my
environment my H a VPN tunnels have a
value of 1000 so I'll configure the
routing priority for the classic VPN
tunnel with the value of 1200 now before
I click Save and continue I actually
have a on-premises router where I need
to make the configuration changes as
well so that traffic is symmetrical
between my H a VPN tunnel pair and my
on-premises router and Google so I'll
configure that in the background and
then I'm going to click Save and
continue here so now that it's
configured if we return to that
hamburger bar menu at the top left hand
side scroll down to V PC Network and
select the routes tab click the dynamic
tab and now we can see that I'm
receiving a route from the on-premises
network with priority 1200 now this was
a priority that I configured towards the
on-prem network as well so traffic is
now preferring my hav p.m. tunnel pair
if I look below here and I returned to
my Pig running in the background
if I stop it I can see that traffic is
now effectively switched over to my new
hav PN tunnel without any interruptions
we can see here that we have zero packet
loss between my pings sent from the GCP
environment to my on premises router now
if I restart the ping I can return to my
VPN configuration under the hybrid
connectivity section if I select the
existing classic VPN tunnel I can safely
delete it now click delete are you sure
you want to delete this tunnel click
delete
now since the traffic is safely going
across the hav pn tunnel pair deleting
the tunnel will have no effect on my
traffic so if i return to the v pc
networks tab
click the routes button click the
dynamic tab now I can see that I'm
receiving the prefix 192.168.1 25.0
slash 24 only from my H a VPN tunnel
pair so if we go back to the panes your
being sent and I stop the pings you can
see effectively I've had zero packet
loss now that I've removed my classic
VPN tunnel and with that we have now a
successful migration from classic VPN
over to H a VPN that concludes the first
migration path from classic VPN
utilizing bgp to h a VPN section to
migrate an existing classic VPN
utilizing policy based VPN to hav pn
between two projects or v pcs within
google cloud now in this section we will
look at configuring hav TM tunnels
between two projects in GCP this
migration path is used to migrate
classic VPN tunnels between two projects
in GC p2h a VPN tunnels let's click the
hamburger menu at the top left hand side
let's scroll down to networking select
hybrid connectivity click the VPN tab
and here as you can see I have
established a classic VPN policy based
tunnel if I scroll to the right you can
see here that there's no dynamic routes
configured in is completely policy based
meaning I've manually configured my
traffic selectors and traffic is going
between this V PC and project to another
project in V PC within gtp now if I open
this new window I can show you I have
another project and in this project I
will go to the same hybrid connectivity
section and the VPN tab and show you the
tunnels that I have created you can see
here I have a existing classic VPN
tunnel which is policy based if I scroll
to the right you can see that it's
established you can also see here that I
have existing tunnels created because
we're going to do B configuration only
in one project so I've already
configured my hav PN's here in this
project we will now create hav pn
tunnels to the new project instead of to
an on-premises network going back to the
original prod
I'll create a new pair of hav PN tunnels
by selecting create VPN tunnel I will
then select the hav PN demo gateway that
I've created before and click continue
so in this case we'll select a pure VPN
gateway type of Google Cloud and here
I'll be presented with a list of
projects that I have access to and I
will select the project that I'm in
attempting to create a connection to by
selecting the VPN gateway name now as
you recall since I've already created an
H a VPN gateway in the other project
this is something that you would have
had to do prior to this step so you
simply follow similar steps that I've
shown you earlier on how to create an
hav pn gateway and you would do that in
one project before the other now once I
select the gateway name here I'm
presented with the high availability
options again very similar from the
previous section here we will create a
pair of VPN tunnels again to provide
high availability with a four nines of
SLA next I will select my existing cloud
routers again you can create a new one
but it's not necessary and now once I
click the VPN tunnels you can see that
they've already been pre associated
one-to-one with the interfaces of my
peer VPN gateway now this is done
automatically for you within Google
Cloud now again similar to before let's
give it a name I'm going to call it H a
VPN peer project - 0 next the same
configuration for Ike version if you
want you can change that next enter a
pre shared key now again a strong pre
shared key is recommended ceilings to
our documentation below for more
information but for this demo I'm going
to select a simple pre shared key
entered I click done next I'm going to
configure my second tunnel by selecting
this tunnel let's give it a name I'm
going to name it H a VPN - Pierre -
project - one next I'm going to enter
the same pre shared key again click them
then create and continue on this page
will create the bgp sessions I've
already created exactly the same thing
here in my other project so I'm only
going to do it here let's click
configure and give it a name so in my
example it's hav p.m. - Pierre - hero
Pierre ASN in my case is sixty five five
zero seven and now for the route
priorities it'll be a little bit
different than the previous example
because policy-based routes have a
default priority in google cloud of 1000
so let's create a route priority that's
higher than the policy-based route so in
lower numerical value as you recall so I
will enter 100 which is lower than the
1000 and then I'll enter the relevant
cloud router and bgp router pure
eyepiece my cloud router IP is 169.254
dot 7.1 and my peers is 169.254 dot 7.2
please note once again that all changes
should be done during maintenance
windows click Save and continue let's
configure the second bgp session click
configure again enter name I'm going to
name it H a VPN - Pierre - 1 and again
enter your ASM in my case that's sixty
five five zero seven the multi exit
discriminator will be the same as before
so for me it's 100 then configure the
appropriate cloud router and BGP peer
IPS in my environment it's one six nine
two five four 8.1 and one six nine two
five 48.2 again click Save and continue
now I won't click Save bgp configuration
just yet and that's because I'd like to
show traffic is currently going across
the existing classic VPN tunnel
and here I'm gonna initiate a ping from
my VM the IP address of my peers
projects VM is 10.30 32
so I'm going to leave the ping running I
can now click save bgp configuration now
here on this page we get the BGP summary
page that you've seen previously we can
click OK at the bottom here you can see
the newly created tunnels and you can
see the pure VPN gateway and the project
that is associated with if we scroll to
the right we can see the current BGP
session status if we click refresh we
can see the BTB peers are established
click on the hamburger menu at the top
left hand side and scroll down to VPC
network and select the routes tab next
select the dynamic tab and now we can
see a destination range of 10 30 30 0/24
which is a new route that was created
across the UK VPN peers if I click the
all tab I can see a policy based route
tunnel with priority 1004 the same
prefix 10.30 dot 30.0 / 24 now traffic
has automatically moved over to the hav
PN pair across these two priority 100
link so if we return to the dynamic tab
again you can see these two priority 100
link and traffic has effectively moved
over to the hav PN tunnels if I return
to my VM window down below I can now
stop the pings and you can see that
traffic has seamlessly switched over
without any packet loss I can then
re-establish the panes go back to my VPN
section and simply select the VPN policy
based routing tunnel and delete it so
again let's go back to the hamburger bar
menu let's scroll down to hybrid
connectivity and VPN select the classic
VPN policy based routing tunnel click
delete are you sure you want to delete
this tunnel click delete and there you
have it we only have h a VPN tunnel left
so the last thing to do is to
the existing classic VPN gateways unless
you're using them for any other tunnels
but if you're not you can safely delete
them if we go back to my VM ping running
here below you can see that if I stop it
there's been no packet loss when the
tunnel was deleted so I can return to my
cloud console scroll down to the V PC
network sections and routes and you can
see here in the all tab I no longer see
the policy-based route to the VPN tunnel
for prefix 10.30 30 0/24
and they're only still being learned via
the dynamic routes in the dynamic tab
and with that this concludes this video
I've posted some useful links to our
documentation below which explained
various topologies and configurations
with hav PN thank you and have a great
day